la Euforia colectiva la atención de
animar a sus elección en medio de una
multitud de personas las zonas de
aficionados son sinónimo del mundial
Pero esta vez en muchas ciudades
francesas dicen que no habrá pantallas
gigantes ni concentraciones masivas las
razones para el boicot son muchas hubo
un aumento de las protestas
especialmente después de que un artículo
de 2021 publicado en el diario usgardien
afirmará que más de 6.500 trabajadores
inmigrantes habían perdido la vida en la
construcción de los estadios de Qatar
Además del historial medio Oriental
negativo del país que acoge el mundial y
del coste energético de las zonas de
aficionados O sea que manifestación
estos acontecimientos estarían en total
conflicto con la sobriedad energética
que exigimos a nuestros ciudadanos
el país del Golfo debe climatizar sus
enormes estadios en el desierto para
muchas ciudades francesas la ubicación
de la Copa no tiene sentido desde el
punto de vista medioambiental la
alcaldesa de lille escribió en Twitter
que su ciudad no verá ni un solo partido
por el para el medio ambiente y las
denuncias de violaciones a los derechos
humanos en Qatar pero es esto
suficientemente horrible no solo hay que
boicotear el mundial entonces hay que
cortarle el paso no venderle más aviones
ni comprarle petróleo siempre lo paso
siempre lo paso mal cuando solo se
boicotean los deportes
Aunque algunos lo consideran un paso
positivo otros han criticado los boicots
por considerarlos hipócritas citando a
París como ejemplo boicotea la copa pero
también ha fomentado la inversión de
Qatar en la capital y hasta ahora no ha
dudado en animar al equipo París
saint-germain de propiedad katari